with the stellar success of the Iron Man
film franchise it's easy to forget that
the golden Avenger wasn't always the
major player in the Marvel Universe that
he is now the characters never exactly
been a c-lister but until robert downey
jr infused the role with his
irresistible humor and charisma you
couldn't exactly call him an a-lister
either because so much of the superheros
popularity is based on the film's it's
easy to forget how much the source
material differs from what you've seen
on the big screen so as a little
reminder here's the untold truth of Iron
Man a different setting the opening
scene of 2008 Iron Man is set in
Afghanistan where Tony Stark is
showcasing his weapons technology but
most Americans probably didn't even know
the name Afghanistan in 1963 instead
Tony Stark's origin in tales of suspense
number 39 was set in a more recognizable
locale to readers of that time Vietnam
according to Stan Lee his goals for the
story of Tony Stark made Vietnam a
fitting setting Lee knew exactly who the
Marvel readership was and he wanted to
create a character that challenged both
himself and his readers represents
everything everybody a boy and his dog
if you only know Iron Man from the
movies you may be surprised to learn
that for the majority of his existence
stark kept his super heroic identity a
secret to the rest of the world Iron Man
was actually Tony Stark's bodyguard a
nameless Good Samaritan keeping the
super rich Stark safe you honestly
expect us to believe that that was a
bodyguard in a suit that conveniently
appeared despite the fact that I know
that it's confusing
Iron Man didn't reveal his true identity
until 2002 is Iron Man number 400 when
he donned his armor in public without
any attempt to hide despite what you
might think it wasn't because of a
villains blackmail or anything he just
did it to save a dog in this story Stark
notices a dog about to get hit by a bank
robbers car and leaps into the fray at
the cost of his secret identity now
that's a lucky pooch truth is
I am Iron Man
you're fired for a CEO and billionaire
Tony Stark isn't great at keeping jobs
in 2004's Iron Man number 78 Tony Stark
was confirmed as the United States
Secretary of Defense his appointment was
short-lived however as part of the
Avengers disassembled event which
featured the Scarlet Witch using her
powers to destroy the team Stark found
himself magically drunk at the podium of
the UN the drunk stark became quickly
enraged and threatened a visiting
politician even for politics threatening
visiting dignitaries with laser blasts
was just a step too far and he soon lost
the cabinet position seems fair but that
wouldn't be his last high-profile
appointment in 2007 at the end of civil
war number 7 Stark was named director of
shield
unfortunately he would lose that
position by 2009 following Secret
Invasion
making matters worse he got replaced by
Norman Osborn the Green Goblin
how embarrassing would you feel about
getting replaced by this guy you know
how much I've sacrificed yeesh
fighting Hawkeye iron man is a founding
member of the Avengers acts as their
main source of finances and as the
supplier of all the stuff they tend to
break
he also has a knack for bringing in
other long-serving Avengers like the
arching Avenger Hawkeye Clint Barton
first found his way into the Marvel
Universe in 1964 s tales of suspense
number 57 enamored by the seductive
Black Widow herself a villain at the
time Hawkeye fought iron man to help her
steel Starks technology a year later in
Avengers number 16 Hawkeye became a hero
as part of the new roster of Avengers
along with Captain America and two other
former villains Quicksilver and the
Scarlet Witch
but just because Hawkeye was on the side
of the Angels doesn't mean that he
wouldn't fight Iron Man again Hawkeye
joined the ranks of another super team
the defenders right before 1973's
Avengers defenders war broke out when
the two teams squared off against each
other
it was Hawkeye and iron man who battled
in 1973's defenders number nine just
can't seem to miss first time for
everything
made you look a true Hulk Buster Tony
Stark and Bruce Banner might be science
Bros and MCU but the two have gone
head-to-head more times than most
friends Iron Man has even managed to get
the upper hand on a couple occasions
Iron Man's first and most memorable
victory over the Hulk occurred in 1980s
Iron Man number 132 in the issue
iron man put 100% of his armors energy
into a single punch and with it he was
able to ko the green Goliath stark
rendered the Hulk unconscious again in
2009's
Mighty Avengers number 22 by blasting
the Hulk with an exploding rocket
booster ironically as successful as the
Hulkbuster suit was an Avengers age of
Ultron Iron Man has never been able to
defeat the Hulk while wearing the
Hulkbuster suit in the comics every Iron
Man Hulk fight involving the Hulkbuster
armor has ended in a canceled fight or
with the Hulk having busted the buster
I'm sorry the Thor Buster armor you hear
a lot about Tony Stark's Hulkbuster
armor but the Hulk isn't the only fellow
Avenger that Ironman developed a
specific armor to counter in Marvel's
2003 three-part mini event stand off dr.
doom manipulated international events to
set Ironman Thor and Captain America
against each other not knowing how else
he could even stand a chance
Stark created his Thor Buster suit
powered by an Asgardian crystal that
Thor had previously given stark as a
gift the Thor Buster rig looked like a
marriage between Tony's classic red and
gold suit and the Destroyers armor but
ultimately it wasn't enough
Thor destroyed the suits reactor and
Tony ejected from the armor the only
thing that seems to get busted when Tony
pulls out a blank Buster suit in the
comics seems to be the suit itself you
happy now thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]